we condemn this barbaric attack
and the cynical arguments to justify it
it is president putin
who is bringing war back to europe
and in these dark hours
the european union and its people
stand by ukraine and its people
we are facing
an unprecedented act of aggression
by the russian leadership against the
sovereign independent country
russian's target is not only donbass
the target is not only ukraine
the target is the stability in europe
and the whole of the international peace
order
and we will hold president putin
accountable for that
later today we will present a package of
massive and targeted sanctions
to european leaders for approval
with this package
we will target strategic sectors
of the russian economy
by blocking their access
to technologies and markets that are key
for russia
we will weaken russia's economic base
and its capacity to modernize
and in addition we will freeze russian
assets in the european union
and stop the access
of russian banks to european financial
financial markets
like with the first package of sanctions
we are closely aligned
with our partners and allies the united
states the united kingdom canada but
also for example japan and australia
these sanctions are designed
to take a heavy toll
on the kremlin's interests
and their ability to finance war
and we know that millions of russians do
not want war
president putin is trying to turn the
clock back to the times
of the russian empire
but in doing so
he is putting at risk the future of the
russian people
i call on russia to immediately stop the
violence
and to withdraw its troops from
ukraine's territory
we will not let president putin tear
down the security architecture
that has given europe peace and
stability over many decades
we will not allow president putin to
replace place the rule of law
by the rule of force and ruthlessness
he should not underestimate the resolve
and strength of our democracies
and history has proven
that societies and alliances built on
trust
and freedom
are resilient and successful and that's
exactly what the autocrats fear
the european union stands with ukraine
and its people
we will continue to support them
ukraine will prevail